[Music]
david is in la hi david welcome to the
ramsay show
hello thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
um i need your advice
because i'm on the verge of making a
serious life decision
i'm currently in the process of buying a
condo with
the mother of my children
we're not married
we've been together for 10 years
the thing is like i said we're not
married or engaged and i don't plan on
asking her to marry me anytime soon
i want to get your advice on what you
think we should do because like i said
we are in the process of buying this
condo
okay
well um
all of the data that i know
uh regarding a situation like yours the
the legal problems that that what you're
entering into is going to present you if
things go sideways
um the uh
the future uh
prosperity of this family unit
uh tells me that
uh marriage is your best answer
uh now uh i'm curious if you're willing
to have babies with her and buy a condo
with her those are both very large
decisions why would you not marry her
um
that's a great point it's just mainly
you said it kind of like as a flex like
i'm i'm not married to her i'm even
gonna ask her to me like like dude
you're already married like you
you're doing all you're doing
i just feel like every time
we get to like at the finish line
uh there's just something that brings me
back and it's mainly just like um she
has a terrible problem with
communication
not just with me but um dude it's too
late to find that out if you bought a
condo and had three kids you made humans
together bro it's
the ship sailed
now you get to decide whether you want
this ship to to to be in the harbor and
have smooth sailing ahead or it could be
a disaster
you're already out and you're already on
the
water
so let me tell you that like my my
mental aspect of how i uh how i see the
the future then right
no no no here's what you're saying i
don't want to marry her i just want to
buy a house and raise kids with her
together for forever
well the thing is like i don't i mean
yeah we've had kids together um
and i've been doing my best you know to
keep
uh i want i want to raise my kids uh i
want my our kids to be in the family
oriented uh you know environment then
make a family make a family
seal it up so you're saying just put up
with like whatever no no no no no
no no dude you're gonna put up with them
anyway you're by now if you live with
her with kids it's the same woman
yeah whatever problem she's got whatever
problems you got they're going to be
there already hold on let me ask i think
i get what you're asking
you're going to buy a house and y'all
are going to live there together
but you're going to see other people who
are going to make you happy
no
no you're going to be true to her
it's because uh yeah and i've been these
10 years okay they've been together it's
just the other day
the other day i saw um
uh one of uh a youtube video dave ramsey
and he was kind of going in on the on
the girl because she was uh getting a
place with her fiance she wasn't married
yet
and i thought to myself like whoa like i
wonder what he would say to my situation
because okay here's what i'm saying
here's what i'm saying i would get
married
because dude you already are married you
just haven't technically done it yeah
okay now here's what that does it does
several things
one is it affects your relationship
and it affects your alls it's the last
like you said over the finish line it's
the last step over the line and it's
going to force you guys to deal with the
relational issues you've got number one
but number two the reason you actually
called was this
it solves all your legal issues
because what you're doing under
california law is you i'm not an
attorney but this is the truth if you
call an attorney
is you're forming a general partnership
and
and both of you are on the deed and both
of you are on the loan and if you have a
blow up
and she takes off
you've got this thing and you can't even
sell it without her signature
and you can't find her because she's
hiding at her uncles in idaho
or vice versa exactly
exactly but if you are married then you
would be going through what's called a
divorce and there's a process for
handling this deed
and getting the property out of your
all's names but you don't have the legal
thing is like
vastly more complicated when you're
shacking up than when you are married in
every state even california which is
immensely complicated but even there
okay and so yeah but and on top of that
um i'm just being your old ugly uncle
boomer uncle right
and
and i'm just loving you and i'm saying
hey yeah man i i you know
i i love you david and i want you to
have the best life for you for her for
those kids and all the data and all the
research indicates marriage trumps
shacking up for the high quality of life
the likelihood of wealth building the
propensity to succeed in your career
all of these things are accelerated the
research piece the researchers call it
the marriage advantage
they find that people who are married
versus people who are single whether
shacking up or not have an advantage
an economic
advantage over a period of 30 or 40
years we see a lift among the marrieds
um versus the singles
i'm not picking on you singles i'm
quoting research to you this is actual
freaking data and stuff like truth in
other words and so
that's what
you know
you know and so yeah that that's a thing
and so what we would tell you because we
care about you not because we're
thumping you with a bible or something
like that we're just
there's just it just works better life
works better this way and you're doing
it all anyway you just got to admit this
to yourself and let me
let me lean into something you mentioned
here brother
you said am i supposed to just take this
no
the answer is no the answer is you're
telling me she's got a communication
problem and you know what she probably
does i trust you and if i sat down with
her she would say i've been with this
guy for 10 years and he and i'm not
coming i'm not good enough i'm unsafe i
feel like i got to yell to get his
attention i got to scream and then you
hear that as communicate and now y'all
are in a dance so you want to you want a
path forward here's the path forward
you walk home and you get on a knee not
to
not to propose to say i'm sorry
for 10 years i've
sent you a message that this is what
your value is i'm always going to hold
you at arm's length until you get
i'm going first and i'm sorry yeah and
i'm asking you can we learn to
communicate in a different way so that
we can get married and move on with our
lives together and the last way to look
at this is if one of those three kids is
one of your daughters
how do you want them handled david
would you put up with this
for on behalf of one of them for a
decade i would have run you off if he
was around one of mine
because you didn't know where the
painter get off the ladder
this is the ramsey show